love this man's working the crown in Mad
Men which you can catch your own
audience every day and Chernobyl which
is it's remarkable a miniseries as
there's ever been on HBO or anywhere and
you can watch it on HBO go on HBO now
right now and I've thrilled to have here
on the Rich Eisen show Jared Harris good
to see you sir didn't see it I'll say it
again this is uh this is not for the
faint of heart
it's remarkable it's a remarkable
achievement that you have been a part of
did you know when you started doing this
that you were part of something special
could you tell at that point in time
Jared well just I knew the scripts were
remarkable and something special but
there's so many things that have to
happen you know in terms of that the
whole team has to hit the bull's eye and
I say this is one of those so rare
occasions where in every department I
mean in you know art direction in
costume the makeup I mean even it's not
that often you've read sort of critical
analysis of a show where even the sound
design has being talked about is having
it in a sort of an effective
contribution to the to the whole piece
so yeah once we were there and we were
shooting you can feel that it's going
well but you know after you're finished
working on something you're basically
kept in the dark knee you have no idea
how coarse the process the
post-production process is going so and
you also you can't predict how how
you're the products or your show's gonna
be received so a lot of that to do with
timing so it seems to have arrived at
the right moment yeah I mean of any time
I've I've watched something see
something TV or movies that I I'm so
moved by I'll read more about it and and
this the articles that I've read about
Chernobyl is the attention to detail is
blowing away people whose job it is to
be expert in the field that you're
portraying down to the uniforms that are
being worn down to like the waste bins
that you better on the set and I'm
wondering how that helped you and
getting into your character into your
role into performing all of that helps
I mean that all helps it's a one less
thing that you doesn't pull you out or
you don't have to think about or worry
about and that was certainly true on
Sage shows like Mad Men or the terror or
this so that where they they are the the
people who are in charge of creating
that world there's a there's a premium
being put on the fact that if you bring
the more authentic the material is that
you bring the happier the director is
the happier the showrunner is you know
I'm you know on Mad Men if you opened a
drawer on that set everything was period
you know there wouldn't have been any
sort of you couldn't open a magazine and
it would not be that month that the show
that episode okay yeah so you're used to
her being on a set like that was it yeah
same way for the crown as well pretty
much yeah everywhere you go and this of
course we shot in a it was a Lithuanian
was part of the Soviet Union and there's
big parts of the country that still have
that sort of Soviet hangover to it in
terms of the the the architecture the
the buildings and and the people there
certainly had lived through the Soviet
era so and we had in the costume
department a part of the crew that they
had had worked in Soviet factories so
they would tell you nothing was cut to
fit and the material was quite strong
some heavy canvas light material say
wouldn't hang on you well and so they
sort of purpose because our thing is to
try and make it look good they went know
it nobody looked good there's nothing
glamorous about this sort of thing the
man who plays Valerie Lagasse off the
Soviet nuclear physicist and in
Chernobyl Jared Harris here on the Rich
Eisen show what did you learn about it
what did you come away with that you
obviously learned a lot about nuclear
physics yeah right you know I could
explain in laymen terms how a nuclear
reactor works I could explain what went
wrong on that night which is you know I
that's a pretty big thing to get your
head around so but luckily Craig had got
his head around
and I just had to figure out what he
wanted me to talk about yeah sure and
obviously this has been a worldwide
reaction to this the Russian
government's not too much of a fan yeah
I mean the Russian government has got
nothing in common with the Soviet
government I mean there it would be like
it would be like Angela Merkel getting
upset about policies of the National
Socialist Party during the 1930s Germany
and that they have no right Russian
governments are democratic government
and this is a yeah I don't quite
understand why they're upset yeah it's
it odd isn't it it's kind of strange
yeah yeah there's apparently they're
gonna do their own version of of
Chernobyl I don't hear an odd thing to
do because they gonna sit I think I saw
somewhere there was gonna be something
about the CIA agent blowing it up but
they don't look good in that version
either because the guy blows it up
that's true it's a failure
that's how does that a better version of
the story Jared I don't think they
thought it completely through I suspect
they'll probably hire someone in
Hollywood to write the story or the
people that are showing up in Chernobyl
in the area right now taking instagram
photographs of themselves
that's weird they I mean apart from
anything else I saw some pictures of
people on swings and things like that
and as far as I understand that the
metal absorbs the radiation and holds it
longer so those are bad places to be
sitting on or resting on or being near
because you you're probably absorbing
more radiation than if you were
elsewhere in that but I would avoid all
those areas one thing that I picked up
from watching this the show jared is
that um it's a dangerous spot for many
many years to come so if you're a fan
yeah and you're fanning out on the show
yeah you would kind of pick up the fact
that it would be dangerous to visit
there well they do
DUS adventure tourism there they and
they you you're taken through and guided
walks and you have to sign something
that you understand the risk you're
taking
but obviously maybe it was in and it was
in Ukrainian that they didn't understand
what they were planning Jared Harris you
can read that's right on the Rich Eisen
show so what sports are you into if any
hi I'm a
big football fan I support Manchester
United
ok I love boxing I used to box when I
was younger I found it harder to to
watch boxing now than the heavyweight
division just collapsed quite a long
time ago but I mean you've got obviously
Tyson Fury is involved in this but he
was in that chair about two weeks ago
this guy's right and yeah he is quite a
specimen I mean I would not imagine
wanting to be in the way of anything
oh it feel like they're bigger but I
don't know if there are these strong
hats the sweet science you know how much
of that again I'll be honest with you I
didn't want to try and float you know
okay it's six foot nine when he stood up
out of that seat yeah and he came on in
in like these pink shorts right these
like hot pink shorts like really sure -
yeah so you know and then no one's gonna
say anything if you're sick and the
[ __ ] Kings showed up with an entourage
that when I went back to say hello to
them sounded like they were extras from
a guy ritchie movie okay he says it
really was just everything that he
brought to the equation was you imagine
that Tyson Fury would bring to the
equation but I know you're an ollie
aficionado correct oh yeah I've big fan
of his growing up yeah so could you
mention when you walked you sat down
here you saw our memorabilia wall
yeah I've been I have a poster of the
ali/frazier fight the first one at
Madison Square Gardens signed by both of
them no kid house haven't gloves signed
by early as well so I mean that's got to
be some of your more prized possessions
that you have in here yes I just write
was such a in great admiration for him
and for for what he did and I'm still
waiting for the the perfect early movie
to be made and and my pitch for it would
be okay it's the three years where he
wasn't fighting and because at that
point of his life he had become such an
effective civil rights advocate and that
he was being courted to run for office
and and he had to make a decision as
towards the end of those three years
we'd won the Supreme Court case is he
could have entered political life public
life as he could or he or he could have
stayed with boxing that's an interesting
story for if you go do a nollie more
profile and courage there's no question
about that obviously what he did and
what he stood for at the time he was to
say the least getting a lot of heat for
you yes and he was just so damn
beautiful as well
well he would tell you - yeah he would
tell that to you yeah and in various
different forms was poetic or just
straight to your face and odd the reason
why I do what I do for a living in many
ways is cuz I grew up a fan of Howard
Cosell z-- okay who who would obviously
have to be part of this film he would
being a guy who would be an announcer
who got in his corner at the time and
there weren't a lot of people in his
corner wait isn't it but yeah they won
he got a lot of flack for that and
that's why you were a fan of his just
though his fighting style as well or
well I used to box at school so you know
you try and copy him which was a
disaster
do you try the footwork I did try rapid
at once but it was a bad strategy
because there was only 3 1 minute rounds
I wasn't long enough to tie the guy at
the strategy that's just the rope or is
that the dope that I was the day I wrote
myself from that but yeah I mean I used
to box at school I remember I remember I
got hit so hard by a guy I mean I got
knocked out but I was standing on my
feet I couldn't see anything but I could
hear still fresh and so I kept I sort of
danced around and kept flinging out a
job hopefully in the direction I thought
he was in they didn't quite realize that
he tagged me otherwise I'd had gone down
but I remember all my vision coming back
ok and it comes back from the outside
and then slowly works its way in and
it's like a lot of little pinpoints of
Carlos it's like stars that slowly come
back in towards the middle and then you
got up no I wasn't down I see oh he just
sort of hit me so hard that I couldn't
see anything I thought it'd be like
Tyson Fury where you're down
all of a sudden you get up just like
that
and so forgive me if I sound ignorant
you're a Manchester United fans yeah are
you did you have no concern about
Liverpool winning or do you care or I
said well I've I've got more friends who
Tottenham fans so okay I was reading for
Tottenham but it also helped that Harry
Kane was on that side as well or no Tina
sure I mean what he did for hard to
watch
I really do I find them hard to watch is
it because they're eventually going to
let you down at the very end or pretty
good this team is pretty good
I think they over achieved amazing yes
they really did actually meet you think
like it was gonna happen no I didn't
know I think it's because you can see
they they they play with fear like at
some point no you can what happens I
think we're happy thing in team is they
go out there in the first twenty minutes
they're just full of adrenaline so they
run like you know like rabbits yes
twenty minutes all over the field and
and I made to wear down their opposition
and they normally score not get an early
goal but then as we know from boxing you
that that thing that you do if you allow
the adrenaline to take hold of you it's
a bad strategy to have because the thing
that happens off the adrenaline wears
off extreme tiredness and huh your legs
become heavy your arms become heavy so
you can see that after that that burst
of adrenaline wears off they suddenly
become they can't move they can't run
right and they just start goofing the
ball so you revert to what you were
taught as a kids which in English
football is kick and run so they stop
goofing the ball up the field and all
the skill goes out and we just looks
just terrible so it's painful it is
painful being an English it's like
you're waiting for the trapdoor to open
up but that much better being in my new
fan of them nice to say it's pretty we
had a very very good run so you can't
complain but it's pretty tough at the
moment Jared Harris here a couple more
minutes left in the Rich Eisen shield I
you said when you sat down on the chair
looked at my show logo you said what jon
hamm said when he saw the show logo for
the first time yeah very Don Draper
locked oh sorry Don Draper
don't Draper on the run there is yeah
exactly he kind of grabbed the mug and
did the Mad Men theme as it was falling
down sort of way being on that show and
you joined it midway through yeah pretty
much as you it was already a big thing
exactly what was it like walking onto
the set with that time I mean I remember
well I I was a fan of the show so I was
excited and intimidated and I also
didn't know I I was only hired for one
episode and lane Pryce is just one
episode that's yeah they said listen
he's not sure what he's gonna do with
the character Bea's definitely once in
for one Episode you might have him he
might ride him in form or he write not
he depends on what he sees happens with
the role so he you know well but we
definitely want the character for one
episode so I saw I was I was sort of
episode 2 episode joining that and I I
mean I'm you know no matter how
experienced you are if you watch the
show you get into the whole imaginative
life of the show when you meet those
people in real life you are a little bit
starstruck so yeah and those guys had
all figured out what they needed to
figure out by then so there's no
conversations about the script the
material the world the style of
performance anything like that you had
to figure that out really quickly well
and there is a similarity I could not
help but notice and I gotta offer
spoiler alert if something happens in
Chernobyl within the first couple of
minutes already
right but lane Pryce and your character
in Chernobyl both meet the same end
that's the writers decided that hmm in
the case of obviously Chernobyl history
it's actually happened well he decided
where to put that event in the storage
reg did and he and Craig used it as a as
a he wanted it to stick in your mind as
to why had he done that so it's a it's a
the mystery at that point correct
that you'll suspend that thought in your
mind as you go through the show but then
very low gas off he did it as a
statement he tried he used it as a an
inciting event to try and get the
scientific community to reveal what they
knew about the the reactors and the
design of the reactors and the cause of
the accident and it worked in that sense
and he only had a couple of years left
him and his daughter was talking about
it recently about how sick he was at
that point it was actually a lot sicker
than we portrayed him to be he was he
was very thin and he had stopped eating
and I mean he was he was very poorly I
mean that's the thing that my wife and I
many times we remarked watching
Chernobyl is the fact that how close to
the building everybody was with nothing
lon
to protect him and I hadn't trained them
so I'm just wondering if everybody knew
just doing their jobs every day was a
death sentence essentially just being as
close to the building as they were
that's the thing that I would believe
the gas off knew that and anyone who had
any kind of familiarity with the nuclear
physics would have understood that the
longer you spent there in proximity to
it you I mean they weren't as close as
the first responders I mean that was
that was an instant death sentence for
those guys and and again they hadn't
been trained in what to do in those
circumstances that only I've been
trained in and what had had handler
conventional fire but but it all
depended once you're the people who had
arrived afterwards and once the fire was
out it's how long you spend in proximity
to that material and also how much of
its coming down on you and sure getting
kicked up in the wind and well I I never
really say this to a guest but having
followed your career and seeing the gas
oven in Chernobyl and lane Pryce in
madman I hope you're not someone who's
trying to quit smoking so now I quit oh
my god I quit yeah no I quick several
years ago it took me seven goes I quit
2004 how the hell are you doing your job
well they're not real cigarette that
you're not allowed to smoke real
cigarettes on sets but so
as they're horrible cigarettes they
taste disgusting so then your acting is
pretty amazing
also the thing about those and this is
true as well for Mad Men like a horrible
cigarettes don't stay lit so our normal
cigarettes they put stuff in it so you
can puff away and hold it and chat for a
bit for 20 30 30 seconds and it will be
lit when you come back to it not herbal
cigarettes so when you see them when
they're going and that's like snacking
on them for their life
it's the reason it's as though they're
trying to keep the damn thing lit it
doesn't go off in the middle of the take
and you have to redo the tape because
the cigarette went out so that's why
they you see like John Hamm and John
Slattery and that's the reason why so i
mandated ask is that real alcohol that
was kind of boring oh that went on
madman when Matt Winer was there there
would be a little little tip a little
something right there by the cameras and
you could go in okay I'm just wondering
well Jared this has been a delight thank
you for coming on Ike I really enjoyed
everything that you've done in Chernobyl
is an achievement that's a that's a word
for it and good luck to you I hope you
get every award did you deserve for this
it's amazing thank you really is at
Jared Harris on both Twitter and
Instagram Chernobyl can be watched right
now on HBO go and HBO now that's how I
took it in and by the way one last thing
to the fact that we're all talking about
this right as Game of Thrones was
hitting a crescendo and ending is a
testament to just how great what you're
doing they gave us a really good leader
no I know that I mean the mother of all
dragons but the fact that that that it
still it was talked about as much as it
was it could easily been lost in that
sure Game of Thrones and that's what you
can't plan it's it is there it was the
right story at the right time and you
can never plan that kind of thing and
it's obviously there's there's a thing
and the sort of the political zeitgeist
the climate change debate all that and
it's not preachy because it's about this
story specifically right it's not trying
to make that analogy but you can see the
the show and see the themes that are
being talked about in it and you can
quite easily make some
transitions maybe the Russians think
it's preachy maybe that's what they're
Jews but again why because it's a
completely different political system I
don't understand yeah maybe they're just
not getting not thinking it all through
lets them old it's the old guard
situations oh they're still they're
still around HBO go or HBO now Chernobyl
is there right now check it out thanks
for coming on the show guard Harris will
wrap up this show and the rest of the
week in a moment for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
unto wreck TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app